[Music]
today's classrooms reflect the
increasingly mobile society we live in
the student population is becoming more
diverse and non-native speakers
constitute a greater portion of
classrooms than in previous generations
or even just a few years ago
parent-teacher conferences are a key
instrument for engaging parents with
their children's teachers and the school
community
but what if parents aren't fluent in the
language of their child's school how can
they gain an accurate picture of their
child's progress how can they target
areas for improvement when there is a
communication gap with the instructor
today microsoft offers a groundbreaking
new tool that bridges the gap between
parents and the teachers responsible for
their child's education microsoft
translator provides real-time
translation in a free easy-to-use tool
that works on any device with web
capability
welcome thank you so much again for
coming today muchos meses bonusing enemy
huh
your son is very kind he's doing really
well in my class as some of them which
had Lydia do you have any other
questions for me going beyond the
classroom there are situations in
education where parents can benefit from
real-time translation into their native
language when parents are able to
efficiently touch base with school staff
navigating school practices and policies
becomes effortless
there are many interactions between
families and schools that are simplified
with translator the setup for Microsoft
translator is so quick and easy just
visit a kms
translator edu to learn more and
download the app then start talking your
conversations await
you